- When people find out I'm
Vietnamese, this always happens.
- Oh my God! I love pho!
- It's pronounced "fuh"
and yeah it's delicious.
But today I wanna spend some time talking
about some other things that
makes being Vietnamese awesome.
(bright music)
Like, aside from pho, we have
some other amazing dishes too.
- What do you recommend?
- Personally, my favorites
are the bún bò huế,
the bánh xèo and the Cơm tấm.
Also, fish sauce is the nectar of the Gods
and it makes all our food
taste that much better.
- Hmm, could use some fish sauce.
- We're able to speak Vietnamese
when we don't want people
around us understanding us.
- [Man In Short Sleeve] Oh,
potatoes, I love potatoes.
French fries.
- On top of the universal holidays,
we also have Vietnamese holidays.
That's double the festive.
- Hey, are you free February 16th?
- Ah, I can't. It's New Year's.
- New Year's was the 1st.
- I know that, I'm talking about
Tet. Vietnamese New Year's?
You know you can't expect this to happen
at the next family gathering.
- [Guest] Kevin
- Hey, Victor.
- Oh my gosh. Is that..?
- Paris by Night? Yeah,
you know how yulin is.
- Of course I do.
- Vietnamese people are some one of
the hardest working people I know.
I've seen families do incredible things
from very little and
they've taught me a lot
about courage, perseverance and love.
And for me the best part
about being Vietnamese
is our strong sense of
community and family.
Oh, and did I mention how
folklore says Vietnamese people
are the descendants of
a fairy and a dragon?
Yeah, we're magical baby.
(bright music)